dan is lovely see here always at London
Film and Comic Con how are you having a
good time today
it's fantastic yeah having a great time
busy warm but great to be here again and
have a chance to say thanks loads of
fans wanting to speak to get your
signature and watch your talks as well
they were unsure when asking you about
the powerful wedding but give us a
little bit of insight for the people at
home behind the scenes of the purple
weddings you know for such a traumatic
episode that was actually that was it
was it was difficult to shoot we shot
the whole thing in five days
so that was an intense week but I think
it was the largest assembly of named
characters the shoe had done so far so
you know cuz you had Bri ng me all the
Royals had you know Charles dance and
Diana and you know myself and Jerome and
all that so it was great we had a big
green room and we got a chance to hang
out a lot with a lot of people that
you'd not worked with before them I
spent a week playing backgammon with
Dean Diana Rigg so it doesn't get much
cooler than that you know she's she's an
absolute just the wonderful room
wonderful woman so it was great fun you
know how much fun was it watching
Joffrey croak on screen what was your
reaction when you saw the half but
obviously knew is gonna happen but
seeing it I was a bit sad I tell ya I'm
an Ole Miss Jack that was a I was a bit
sad but what are their you know what a
way to go out there they managed to get
a spot on so if you're going to go out
go out and such a way we've seen the
scene with you and Tyrion where you can
visit him in the south as well I was
really kind of heart-rending wasn't it
and we've seen you of course of Brienne
as well as season that relationship has
that changed tell us a little bit about
how was filming that sync with the piece
of English first of all was Tyrion and
also how you felt about how the
relationship with Brianna's develop yeah
that scene I think when I read that
scene that was the scene I was most
excited to see after shooting it and it
was also the scene I was most nervous
about doing just because I was standing
taller to a Peter Dinklage you know and
yeah I was nervous but it came out
looking really nice so that was a lot of
fun and and it was nice to have
something to get my teeth into and in
terms of the character showing a bit
more of himself yeah I'm going off with
a wig when you know it's just nice to
mix things up and and to what was
suddenly fresh and she is just amazing
and we have you know we had a great time
last year and you know hopefully will
will continue to have a great time but
as long as they want to keep us that
season finale was quite something wasn't
it Brienne versus the hand if your neck
ear biting crotch kick in oh my god that
was painful what was it like being there
at close what should be in film to be
honest Maisie and I sat on a hill for a
couple of days just listening to music
and chatting because because so much of
it was stunt doubles and and you know we
weren't involved in the fight so it was
really nice in terms of that that was
the first property me and I got a chance
to chat so it was a great it was really
nice to watch it from a distance and not
have to run about in the Sun and are
modern and be really hot that was nice
to chill out and it was great did you
think it's great after unbelievable it's
it's maybe the single best fight I've
ever seen and any medium you know TV
film whatever as a one-on-one fight goes
I don't think anybody's ever thought
that that was spectacular a pretty good
one they didn't we with the Viper and
Mountain what was your reaction when
you're watching that will the iCarly
goodness knows well again you know Pedro
so nice and also the character was so
cool it's just such a such a kick in the
balls that he gets taken away from me
after less than a season but that was a
great fight and you know Game of Thrones
does what Game of Thrones does best you
know what you least expect and it yeah
it was a very exciting to watch that any
great death is also for but over in my
tower but a fantastic death also for
Tywin at the end of the season as well
they didn't stop it though no no that
was at the sort of the list at the end
of the season just a major named after
major named after major name he just
kept taking people off and you were just
getting over one day then they hit me
with another one and you were still more
than that person and they hurt you with
another one and yeah very exciting a ton
again it funds the whole thing on its
head you know Joffrey dies but but
Tywin's still there and he's always the
man who's in power but then failing
boards so what what does that mean it's
it's all very exciting to see what's
going to happen next what would you like
to see happen next or pod Embree and
what are the same more of the same
it would be great if you know they they
did find Sansa that'd be really nice but
I would just love to see more poor than
Brienne getting to know each other and
Brienne realizing pods useful nor
useless
he has is yes his moment yeah so that
would be nice just to spend a bit more
time in the roads
we began to fight or to universe done
it's been a pleasure as always as always
thank you pleasure zone me
you